I often do look at the pile of stuff at
work and think maybe I should stick that
on my face the Bob bugs project started
was just my Instagram account and I
started using it for an art diary I got
an idea every day i disguised myself in
some way day 363 now for a creative
breakthrough my name is Michael Gump
I am art director and a prop master for
crazy TV shows and I'm also known as Bob
bugs the master of disguise project is
partly to build creative strength or
maybe to like exorcise creative demons
you know in a way that's not just at my
job but also for my own evil wishes you
look at the picture maybe seems like it
took a million years I'm usually like I
had ate this done I gotta get that side
just like I get my stuff and it's it all
up and searched
so I usually like you know start with
this area and then work my way out and
then it'll be like
people asked me what time like how many
people have you have to help you with
that usually nobody does it huh one that
stands out in my mind was kind of like
what am i doing I was putting clothes
pins on my face and so I started stick
him on there and then and then I kind of
panicked a little bit I took them all
off I was like okay and then I was like
okay let's this is gonna be fine and
then and then I put them all back on
like you get used to discomfort pretty
fast
but I'm concerned that it's definitely
not that good for my skin do you have a
favorite I do have a special place in my
heart for the one that's like a green
mr. t because I just think it's funny
like mr. green tea I call it it's been a
kind of exhausting process in some ways
I usually only get like maybe three
hours of sleep a night the discovery of
the project and part of the point of the
project is that you don't always know
what's good so on the days that I really
feel tired I really want to do it I
don't really have a very good idea
sometimes those projects come out better
than the ones that I'm really excited
about what's next we wrapped wait and
see
you